joining me here now on the Rich Eisen
show is none other than Hall of Famer
Jerome Bettis how do you like those
words together Jerome wow that's
incredible that it's one of those you
don't think whatever happened you don't
think that's associated with your name
until someone says that it's special
well Jerome you're a special guy man
anybody who's ever met you and I've
known you for Wow gosh 12 years ever
since you hung out with the NFL total
access crew bowling with us of generic
first three months of existence and
getting to know you and who you are I'm
talking to you as you know from our la
Studios if I had told you when you were
in la Ram Jerome that this would be
where you wound up at the end of your
career what would you have said I would
have said yeah you got to be kidding me
because you got to remember when I was
in LA I had just just went to of that
position I was a full back in college I
didn't know much about you know being a
tailback and the responsibility so I was
making a tremendous change and I thought
that if I could last a couple years
that'd be great I'd had no idea that you
know I would be able to play even 13
years so to say hey you'll be a Hall of
Famer that that would would have been
something far-fetched in my opinion what
was that moment when you were when you
wound up in Pittsburgh what was your
thought process in your career back then
Jerome well my thought process i'll
never forget what I thought when that
went when coach coward called me and
said hey you know we want to you know on
the stillers it was one of those man
this is incredible because they had just
lost in the Super Bowl so I'm saying man
this is a super bowl-caliber team I went
from a perennial loser um you know that
was in LA and then who would we went to
the went to st. Louis to now a team that
had just lost in the Super Bowl and they
had that kind of talent still on the
team I was super excited to be going
there because i just knew i was going to
have a lot
a success with that group of guy I'm
here with the bus Jerome Bettis Hall of
Famer going in the Pro Football Hall of
Fame coming up in august right here on
the rich eisen showed you know who's
going to present you yet Jamie I'm
working on that process I mean it's kind
of interesting my you know my mom my
father would have been the natural
candidate yet but obviously he's no
longer with us so my brother maybe my
mother but my wife I actually kind of
said hey what about me I mean it was
kind of funny but uh it was one of those
thoughts and I have a son he said it I
don't know if he sees it look quite big
enough yeah I'm still kind of wind
surely and all the options right now hey
Jerome I remember speaking of your dad
after the superbowl win in Detroit do
you remember that when you came on post
game show on and I had about 20 on my
entire family behind the stage use me
you Ray Lewis trust me I remember like
it was yesterday Jerome I think you are
vastly underestimated the number of
people that were there I think my memory
again I might be you know in some
saturday i am a member in stayed here i
would number out there i had to have 40
i had over 40 tickets oh wow i'm sure he
was and it was there though upward to
that number they were all there though
Jerome and I just remember you know
sometimes my job is to just lay out as
they say in the TV business and just let
the moment play out and that was one of
those moments for me what is your
recollection you know celebrating that
moment with your dad I believe you
passed a few weeks later if i'm not
mistaken so what was that moment like
for you Jerome it was you know it was a
special moment because you know he was
you know he was my biggest fan he didn't
care about the all the hook line or that
he just cared that his son was playing
football he was passionate about me and
everything that I did I mean he could
tell you numbers and everything like
that about me and in it was one of those
he was he was all about the things that
I was able to accomplish so how was
happy in that moment that he am
mother was there to share with me
because if you remember they made it to
every single game i ever played in in in
professional my professional career so
for them to be there for it to be in
detroit the culmination of my career for
for my mom and dad to see it from
beginning to end and it in with a super
ball i was so happy for both of them
because they got an opportunity in
retrospect I'm um I was not much more
happier that he got an opportunity see
you know his son become a champion in
and obviously the the regret now is they
didn't get an opportunity see me become
all favors yeah but we know he does you
know yeah exactly exact we know that
Jerome Jerome Bettis right now Hall of
Famer here on the Rich Eisen show okay
so Jerome Super Bowl let's say let's say
Super Bowl 40 let's say it was closer
than the final score of that game Super
Bowl 40 here we are you're got a half
you've got a half yard line situation
there's thur let's just say I'll throw a
number out there 30 seconds left in this
game in the Super Bowl and there's a
pass play that's called instead of
handing the ball off to you what do you
do about that your own medicine oh my
goodness what did I am livid hi I'm love
oh I am super mad and there was a case
not of this magnitude but we had a game
we're never forget it we were playing
jacksonville i believe it was it was in
i think we were in overtime or something
like that and it was it was a
fourth-and-one player 31 playing I'm and
they didn't put me in and in that play
um quarterback fumbles the ball it gets
picked a run back for a touchdown we
lose the game and I'm Santa myself are
you kidding me you don't put me in four
hours I mean I was pissed and I made I
made it known uh you know you're my
resentment for that situation because
the point I'll make it as you have me on
the team for this reason and now you in
the moment
where you have to make a decision you go
away from what you do best uh to do
something else I was I was offended and
I would if I was mashonaland I would be
offended as well I'm saying this is your
brand butter this is what we do listen
this is not the time to go away from it
lets you know we've got two timeouts we
should try to polish thing 12 times for
down hey that's the moment of truth
that's when you got an option runner
past and you maybe you put in Russells
his hands at that point but you go with
what you can what you know and I think
that's what they went away from well
Jerome also that help that was the final
play as we all know from scrimmage for
Seattle and New England's of a champion
and Bradys got four rings now you were a
part of the worldwide leader in sports
trio of analysts after the brady press
conference where Brunel was moved to
tears essentially and do you still feel
that brady was being less than honest in
that press conference or the information
that's trickling out about the football
since then has changed your mind where
do you stand it no there's nothing that
changes my mind because the problem here
is if you can explain to me why the
Colts balls were not changed in any way
at any point in time the you know the
weather the bear metric or whatever you
want to call it if you can tell me that
it affected the Colts balls then I
understand that well from my point of
view you cannot and and nobody's point
of view you can explain the differences
with the boss and so with that being
said yes someone new clearly someone new
Tom Brady understood what type of all
that he likes mmm now he can say he
didn't know that it was not you know at
the proper amount he could say that but
you can't say that the balls were the
same as the all the other bomb
she he can't say that because when when
I felt that ball I knew that ball was
different from the other boss there's no
question about that you sure do wrong
anybody it listen to me anybody else
who's played this game for a long period
of time and it's touched a football
regularly can tell you the difference
okay now you said to ask a defensive
lineman yet he probably couldn't tell
you but a guy who handles the football
on a regular basis can tell you that a
ball is the difference from wherever was
10 5 to 12 you can tell the difference
that's that's not even a question about
that part so deflategate is not over for
you Jerome Bettis no it's not open it's
not over for anyone i mean it's not over
it's not over period i mean if you look
at the Atlanta Falcons a lot of stalkers
now there they look like you know they
piped in noise right yes so so now there
isn't a competitive advantage that they
gain right so this going to have to be
ramifications there so now if there's
ramifications for the latter Falcons if
if there's going to have to be some
ramifications there again if you find
that there was an issue and there
clearly was an issue because the balls
were not the same so there was an issue
not a question is who did it if you
can't find out who did it then you know
hey it was done and you have to pay uh
the penalty for that it may not be a
significant a penalty if we know who did
it but it still has to be some type of
penalties because there was a
competitive advantage that was reached
so my last question for you my last
question for you this is Jerome and you
know I say this with love because you
know again we go way back Jerome we go
way back you know where I'm going with
us are you sure your comments on Brady
aren't said because he went to the
greatest institution of higher learning
an institution that your institution of
higher learning is running like chickens
from playing anymore are you sure this
isn't some sort of michigan notre dame
thing
going on Jerome you sure don't see my
goodness but seriously now I don't
helmet eyes you and put you on a couch
and get your you're in your your inner
psychology for all of the viewers and
listeners of the shoulder out there are
you sure this isn't part of that Jerome
Bettis well let me ask you this part
okay for I answer that question yes do
do you have a horse in the race in
regards to either University of course I
do absolutely i doing Jojo sure so so
let's let's be less for the listeners
sake yes know that there is a bias okay
from the interview perspective ok so
with that being said clearly there is a
bias from my notre-dame perspective okay
15 respect superglue every card is on
the table here in every card / table or
but i will say but yes but that would
that that does not and should not ever
come into play as an analyst hmm ok now
from a notre dame perspective absolutely
i love those guys almost guys in that
color that the off blue colored envoy
that color that those guys in all you
guys stink absolutely Jerome said yes
yes but I would not ever put my personal
personal belief in a situation okay
dealing with a UH NFL issue ok Jerome
I'm glad we cleared that error some
water and thank you for what thanks for
calling in I look forward to seeing you
again real soon no prob thanks for that
you bet that's the man that's Jerome
Bettis the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience